well,
the body of former senator from nevada harry
reid rests in the capitol rotunda
how are you greeted by cristian cásseres
these are images from washington
dc live where fellow family leaders
and the public pay their last tribute
to the senator from nevada who passed away
last  december 28 after a long
battle with pancreatic cancer
a tribute here in las vegas was held
this past
saturday schools will be closed for five
days following rising case numbers
kobe clark county school district will
cancel classes starting  from
Friday and until Tuesday of next
week according to officials the decision
was also impacted by the short
work days they have faced due to
absences due to virus infections
Monday is the holiday for Martin
Luther King Juniors but classes will
resume next  January 19
and I tell you that a piece of news that we have
been following for several weeks
reports that the employee  since he was shot
11 times in men during in chinatown he
is heading for recovery the
restaurant in hyde 6 revealed the
medical condition of zeng guang who
underwent three surgical treatments due to
injuries from the shooting the victim
is in the
rehabilitation hospital  A valley expansion
continues and now
plans for a new development
southeast of Samuel have been unveiled at Jaguar Corporation.
Yus has been developing Morel
for more than 30 years. Company officials
say the Las Vegas Valley
is facing a  real estate shortage and
that they have land for the
construction of more than 560 new
homes near the tropicana area and
town center drive heading south and
we continue with pleasant temperatures as we
touch the navel of the week we will have
blue skies and cool temperatures
for Wednesday morning  Most
temperatures through the valley will be in the
30s and 40s as lows but
highs in the 60s  Don't forget to
enjoy the day as a
sunny Wednesday awaits I'm Cristian Cáceres
with super informative
Spanish Kirchner good day
[Music]